we are getting a close look this morning
at the secluded Island where the late
Jeffrey Epstein is accused of
trafficking underage girls we're also
hearing a first-hand account from one of
those alleged victims little st. James
off the coast of st. Thomas was
privately owned by Epstein until his
death in August the local government is
now suing his estate for control of it
it's also providing new details of how
Epstein was able to get away with his
alleged crimes for so long
mola legi is on a boat near little st.
James well good morning you know there
are really only two ways to get out to
this island either by helicopter or
private boat and that seclusion appears
to have been by design making it
difficult for government officials to
monitor Jeffrey Epstein's behavior here
on the island and even harder for the
alleged victims who were brought here to
escape little st. James may look like a
tropical getaway but authorities say
Jeffrey Epstein used the private island
to hide his criminal activity so you
felt that you can basically be protected
or you could get away with things you
can get away with it Denis George became
Attorney General of the US Virgin
Islands just months before
Epstein's death by suicide last year her
office is now suing Epstein's estate why
pursue these sort of charges now well
all I'll have to say is why not now I
cannot speak for what happened in the
past at all what I do know is that
because of Epstein's wealth and power he
was able to conceal a lot of this
Epstein acquired little st. James in
1998 and nearby great sage James 18
years later the lawsuit seeks to
confiscate Epstein's property including
the islands valued at 86 million dollars
the convicted pedophile registered as a
sex offender in the Virgin Islands in
2010 after serving time in Florida for
procuring an underage girl for
prostitution but George says monitoring
Epstein on his Island came with unique
challenges for authorities checking up
on they were stopped at the dock
and they were told that no this is as
far as you can go because this is my
private property I would not allow you
to go in and in further court documents
allege Epstein flew into Sarah Lee King
Airport the only Airport on st. Thomas
and the same one we flew into earlier
this week the area that the private jets
fly in he's separate and apart from
where all the commercial ok commercial
flights okay and that also helps with
the concealment from there
Epstein allegedly shuttled underage
girls to the island using two
helicopters
according to the complaint air traffic
controllers another airport personnel
reported seeing Epstein with girls who
appeared to be as young as 11 the
Attorney General tells us Epstein
controlled all communication and
transportation on little st. James and
that his alleged victims were
essentially trapped
remember he owns a whole aisle and the
sole it wasn't a situation where's a
child or a young woman would be able to
just break away and run down the street
to the nearest police station Epstein's
island here is about two miles from st.
Thomas according to the lawsuit one of
his fifteen-year-old alleged victims was
so desperate to escape she actually
tried to swim away another of Epstein's
alleged victims who spoke to CBS News on
the condition that we conceal her face
and voice tells us what she said
happened to her he raped me
he brought me off the island actually
took office and st. Thomas and he
actually raped me in his office he also
trapped me in his room on the island
where he had a gun strapped to the
bedpost
I couldn't leave the only means of
getting off the island was either
helicopter or boat attorney Jordan
Merson represents several alleged
victims suing Epstein's estate he's
encouraged others to come forward and
file complaints against the estate
before the legal window closes for those
people who think that they have more
time than March 12 2020 they may be
wrong and they may never get their
chance at justice if they do not come
forward now
well Jeffrey Epstein's estate is
disputing claims that it would use a
Victims Compensation Fund to somehow
conceal alleged criminal activity in a
statement to CBS News the estate says
potential victims would be
under no obligation to keep their claims
confidential recibió this morning mola
legi off little st. James in the US
Virgin Islands
we know so much about what allegedly
happened in his townhouse in New York
yeah there's so much we don't know about
what happened on that island and also at
a remote ranch he had in New Mexico
there's just there's a lot of mystery
surrounding both of those properties
it's just so guys the more you hear the
more despicable and sickening it is the
ages of the girls the way they were
frightened the way they were treated
it's very very hard for and we still
aren't really sure how many of them
there were there were doesn't Maine ever
know yeah well I hope you I hope we do
get answers on this for a lot of reasons
you